but we're going to begin with breaking
news overnight and a crisis averted in
the nation's capital last night the
Senate approved legislation to raise a
debt ceiling and avoid a U.S default now
it's based on a deal that President
Biden and house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
negotiated the agreement has major
implications for the funding of
government services Nicole Killian
followed all of this from the beginning
and joins us now from Capitol Hill
Nicole they were all on The Struggle Bus
for hot second but how soon do you think
this could go to the president's desk
now that it's apparently done and done
well good morning Gail President Biden
will address the nation tonight he says
he will sign this bill as soon as
possible calling it a big win for the
economy and the American people
on this vote the A's are 63 the Nays are
36 the 60 vote threshold having been
achieved the bill is passed the U.S
Senate power through a package to raise
the nation's debt limit for two years
and reign in federal spending we may be
a little tired but we did it so we're
very very happy the bipartisan vote
followed a day of high drama in the
upper chamber as some Senators saw
changes to the house bill this bunch of
request falls woefully short several
Senate Republicans secured new
commitments to prevent automatic Cuts in
the bill from kicking in and a pledge
for additional military aid to support
the war in Ukraine and other Global
threats we need Safety and Security
South Carolina's Lindsey Graham made the
request concerned the deal didn't raise
defense spending enough I know and
divided government is tough but don't
tell me that this is the best we could
do other Senators tried and failed to
strip out a provision to expedite energy
projects like a pipeline in Senator Joe
manchin's home state of West Virginia
what do you say to your colleagues who
think you got a special carve out in
this bill I think that basically we have
to look at the need that we have for the
energy in our country but what does a
pipeline have to do with the debt limit
well no you just basically have to have
legislation that's necessary to use a
vehicle you have and this is the vehicle
that we have let's beat it with the
default deadline approaching in three
days a race to the finish the Biden
McCarthy deal is not conservative in any
way shape or form this isn't the piece
of legislation I would write but at the
same time we can't risk defaulting on
the full faith and credit of the United
States
even though this bill has cleared
Congress the treasury Department is
already taking some extra steps to avoid
default today it is auctioning off about
15 billion dollars in bills to raise
Cash Flat
all right Nicole thank you very much